today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
we have a real and true national
security red alert here to discuss
and it comes down to fundamentally
a pushing through the last
possible stand of uh
keeping something sacred in the sense of
keeping it
outside of the reach of political
machinations or machinations as some
like to say which is that
donald trump's intelligence officials
are no longer going to be briefing
democrats with a question mark as to
whether they will be briefing joe
biden as the nominee of the democratic
party
for president and uh house member
adam schiff has sounded the alarm on
this over the weekend he said that
his committee may end up having to
subpoena intelligence officials because
john
ratcliffe who's the director of national
intelligence announced
that regular election security briefings
were going to be scaled back ahead of
the general election instead of actually
briefing
uh members of the democratic party they
are going to give them some written
documents which of course provides no
opportunity to ask questions now this
is not only obviously political
but it is also obviously related to
upcoming election interference that the
trump administration itself
doesn't have an interest in stopping why
because on balance it's expected to be
beneficial to him so here is donald
trump being asked about this
recently he says the reason is leaks
leaks leaks adam schiff and whoever they
would brief
would just leak the information take a
look whether it was shifty shift
or somebody else they leak the
information before it gets in
and what's even worse they leaked the
wrong information
and he got tired of it so he wants to do
it in a different form because you have
leakers on the committee
obviously leakers that are doing bad
things
probably not even legal to leak but
we'll look into that
separately but they were leaking the
information as brought in how
you don't have that in texas ken you
wouldn't allow that in texas
i guarantee ken will not be allowing the
leakers to be doing that so
we were he wanted to make sure that it
doesn't leak yeah please mr president
one
question so this is a lie that this is
just not true
the real reason why the trump
administration
has directed the intelligence community
to stop briefing democrats as reported
by politico
is that classified security briefings
were given to members of congress and
in those briefings william evening who's
the direction
director of the national counter
intelligence and security center
said russia is trying to help
trump win russia is trying to denigrate
joe biden in order to help donald trump
win
win so what does the trump
administration do they say
stop telling democrats that that's
what's going on
um you might remember and this is why
this is so important i mean
we don't have to theorize about the
implications of this
think back to 2016. when barack obama
was president
and donald trump was the challenger the
republican nominee
barack obama's intelligence officials as
is tradition as should be the case
briefed barack obama and donald trump
about russia's interests in helping
donald trump to win
about the steele dossier and the
information contained
within it and if you think back to that
and you uh consider
the importance of these briefings you
then very quickly realize
the only real reason that donald trump
would have
to say stop briefing democrats is he
doesn't want them to
know what is in those security briefings
because it is not particularly good for
donald trump for that information to be
known and
what we know what william evanina was
saying
has been reported otherwise which is
yeah russia prefers
donald trump period now many will write
to me and say but david
china prefers biden and iran prefers
biden
okay yeah we i've told you that we've
discussed that uh
that that i'm not denying that
and there are geopolitical reasons for
all of the preferences that other
countries have but donald trump is
specifically trying to prevent
one perspective from getting out there
and that is that once again russia has
an interest in helping donald trump win
so
these people need to be held accountable
uh step one for accountability is
november third
that's the most pressing one it's
september now we are two months uh
we we are just weeks essentially from
this election
votes are going to start being cast in
some places i think it's within 10 days
some states
will start early voting so step one for
holding accountable
is removing donald trump then we are
going to have to see
where the chips fall and who was
involved in wrongdoing and while there
is
i believe no real possibility that
donald trump
is charged with anything once he's no
longer president i know that there's
people dreaming of trump in handcuffs
that's not what the u.s
does to former presidents it's not my
opinion
it's just the reality that doesn't mean
that there aren't other people
could it be junior could it be jared
kushner could it be people whose names
maybe we don't know
who should and could be held accountable
and we're going to have to see
they're not even trying to hide it
there's foreign meddling again
and trump's interference is in getting
in the way of people learning
about what russia is doing consider that
and by the way just look back at the
last four years
of getting in the way of any serious
attempt to actually stop
foreign meddling why would he try to
stop it it's useful
to him okay i want to have a
conversation about
polling that is a careful conversation
and a sober conversation because there's
been a narrative building over the last
maybe 10 to 14 days that biden is
falling and trump is rising and
that this is objectively a disaster for
joe biden
and donald trump has actually applied
the term plunging
for geor not not for someone's neckline
who he's trying to talk to but plunging
from the standpoint of joe biden's
polling now the reality is
when we started getting these polls two
months ago that said
biden is up by 10. biden is up by 12.
biden is up by 15. i told you joe biden
is not going to win the popular vote
by 15 nor by 12 nor by 10. the polls are
going to tighten
and depending on how you look at it the
polls are tightening
joe biden is starting
to campaign in a bit of a different way
as a result as we get closer to the
election and that makes sense
donald trump tweeting as i told you
yesterday quote joe biden
is coming out of the basement earlier
than his hoped for 10 days
because his people told him he has no
choice
his poll numbers are plunging
so let's know the facts but let's also
not become overconfident as a result of
those facts
so first of all have the polling
averages tightened you can always find
one poll that will say almost whatever
you want but what about the averages
the real clear politics average was
biden a couple of months ago
and it's tightened by a couple of points
to biden plus seven
okay it it's tighter we never really
expected biden to win by 10 in the
popular vote
would have been completely historic and
indeed the numbers have tightened from
biden with a nearly 10 point lead to a
seven point lead
in the 538 um a polling average
model you see that joe biden now is plus
7.7
at one point he was plus 9.6 that was
back
in early july so yes the polls have
tightened
is joe biden plunging no the answer is
no
and of course donald trump lies all the
time he lies and says coronavirus is
surging in new zealand when it's not
he says he's done a great job on the
virus when he is not he said in april 15
cases would soon be zero that didn't
happen we have six million
just because donald trump is wrong
about joe biden's polling plunging
doesn't mean
trump can't necessarily win and that's
where i want to
sort of go next it's really important
that our actions not be influenced
by these dumb narratives that are put
out there either by donald trump or
others
is po if polling is tightening you have
to vote and i have to vote
if polling is not tightening you have to
vote and i have to vote if trump
is tr is right that biden's polling is
plunging you have to vote and i have to
vote
that's the primary message here and i
know it's like a broken record at this
point but you're only going to have to
deal with it for two two more months
which are arguably going to be long
months but it's only two more months and
as a reminder
if you go back to september 1st of 2016
and look at the polling
between hillary clinton and donald trump
september 1
2016 four m four years ago today
hillary clinton was plus 4.9 and of
course
we know she ultimately lost the
electoral college is biden's lead bigger
as of today yes
it's almost three points bigger than
hillary's four years ago
but so what why take a chance because
there are things going on this year that
are not in the polls
in other words voter purges are not
part of biden's seven point lead right
now planned voter suppression
is not part of the seven point lead joe
biden has right now
messing with vote by mail and the post
office and everything we've been talking
about for the last six weeks
that is not in the polls right now voter
intimidation
at the polls this vague idea that there
might be someone who knows a militia
troops
who knows what at the polls intimidating
voters that's not in the polls
so let's act as if remember
your vote could decide the outcome of
your state
individually it's unlikely any of our
one
votes will do that but collectively
if we all thought our vote didn't matter
and stayed home we actually would be
influencing the results of the states so
that's the correct approach there's no
downside
joe biden's polling is not plunging it's
tightening as expected
we've got about eight weeks to go and
this is the time uh
let me know where you are on the polling
i'm on twitter
at deepakman and remember that you can
get the daily
audio podcast every single day
on whichever is your preferred
podcasting platform
itunes stitcher google play
spotify pandora pod bean
etc there's a lot of them uh we'll see
you in just a couple of minutes
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in
15 minutes blinkist makes sure that
you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to
blinkist.com slash david pakman
i've put the link right underneath this
video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay so i've got a bunch of clips to
play for you we're going to get them out
of the way in this segment then move on
to an interview we've got a lot of a lot
of other things but i i
your if i didn't cover this you'd really
be missing a lot of important
uh sort of narrative changes that are
taking place right now
uh from the white house and in the
context of the 2020 presidential
election donald trump
uh did both a press briefing and an
interview with fox news host laura
ingram
last night i'm going to start with the
interview with laura ingram which donald
trump was promoting
all day multiple times tweeting things
like for example i will be interviewed
on ingram angle tonight at 10 p.m on fox
news
enjoy and there are a lot of really
interesting sort of psychological
dynamics going on right now in terms of
donald trump taking on these interviews
and
winging rallies as he said in new
hampshire over the weekend and so on
because remember that donald trump
believes he always is the smartest
person in the room and that no matter
what people throw at him he's going to
come out
looking good and this is why donald
trump at least seemed open to the idea
of sitting down with robert mueller back
during the russia investigation days
something which his lawyers
knew would be a terrible idea that
donald trump would lie
he would perjure himself it would be a
disaster and they were able to keep him
from doing it and so
the context of trump coming in thinking
he's going to be super effective
went bad really quickly yesterday in
this interview with laura ingraham where
she regularly would try to sort of
interrupt and redirect
trump because she realized that he was
going in a completely wacky
direction there are probably more than
just these instances i'm going to play
for you and we'll look at some of these
in more detail
but look at all of these moments where
laura ingram
just interrupting trump to try to divert
or redirect
what are disastrous paths for him to be
taking essentially trying to
save donald trump from himself they say
that when you walk through
the streets of portland
this is years and years of burning and
it's in the last 90 days it's been
really no no it's been
horrible in the last 90 days but no it's
people that are in the dark shadows
people that what does that mean that
sounds like conspiracy theory
dark shadows people that you haven't
heard of they're they're people that are
on income housing and with that comes a
lot of other problems including crime
may not be nice to save
people or criminals though no i'm not
saying that at all but it does
there is a level of violence in the
meantime he might have been going for a
weapon and
you know is a whole big thing there but
they joke just like
in a golf tournament they miss a three
foot you're not comparing it to golf
because of course that's what the media
i'm saying people choke people people
choke
and now i do wonder you know we'll never
know but
does someone go to laura ingram and say
listen if trump starts going down this
path or
that path try to interrupt it try to get
in the way or is she doing that out of
her own
desire to help donald trump we don't
know now
let's look at some of the details of
what was discussed we talked
yesterday about donald trump bringing in
this guy
a neuroradiologist a doctor but not
someone who has anything to
you know any expertise in infectious
disease scott atlas who is pushing
for a herd immunity approach to dealing
with the virus i told you yesterday why
it would be a disaster
here is donald trump now i told you it
would happen donald trump's starting to
push this idea
mission of americans frankly in both
parties who
aren't comfortable well once you get to
a certain number
you know we use the word heard right
once you get to a certain number
it's going to go away so you know it
doesn't have to be
but yeah i mean a lot of people are not
going to want to do it a lot of people
don't want to
do the flu should it be mandatory you
know i never had the flu but i never had
a shot i never had the vaccine
i come here the first thing sir you have
to have a flu shot
i said why because you have to have it i
say what's the percentage and i wasn't
thrilled with the percentage you know
it's like
fifty-five well dr fauci said it might
not give quote great protection
because it's a coronavirus well i said
look if i've never had it wouldn't it be
good
and then i thought i should have it
because i'll set an example so i had it
so i've had it now
three times but and i still haven't had
the flu
so maybe i'll give credit to the flu
vaccine i don't know so
of course donald trump seems still to be
confused about flu vaccines we're gonna
skip that just because i can't cover
everything
but i did the math for you on herd
immunity yesterday so
here are the numbers for the level of of
contagion
for how easily spread coronavirus is to
get to herd immunity you need 50 to 83
percent of the population to be immune
if you pick a number in the middle it's
67 it's like two-thirds
now with a one percent death rate and
331 people
331 million people in the country if you
do some back-of-the-envelope math
if two-thirds of the country gets the
virus
that's about 220 million if one percent
die
it's about 2.2 million deaths meaning we
still have 2 million deaths to go
to get to herd immunity if you think the
death rate is more like .75
then you're still looking at about 1.5
million dead
from where we are today so the herd
immunity idea is downright
dangerous and donald trump understanding
nothing
is pushing it okay let's continue donald
trump
suggests listen if you don't count the
state of new york
in coronavirus numbers we're doing way
better
bad decisions on nursing homes he's the
number one state in the country by far
for death i mean probably in the whole
world for death you take new york out of
the equation
i think we have among the best numbers
anyway but you take new york we have the
best numbers in the world countrywide
no andrew uh so this this is
one of those meaningless claims right
if you take out the top five states our
numbers are way better
if you don't include nursing homes we
reduce the death toll by like 40
if you take out people over age 75 this
virus really hasn't been that much of a
disaster
this is imaginary nonsense does trump
know that it's nonsense
i don't know i actually don't know here
is donald trump
sort of weirdly second guessing police
incidents and we saw a little bit of a
preview of this earlier in the
compilation of laura ingraham trying to
help trump
hear trump likens police incidents to
putting in golf where sometimes
people choke you know a joker they choke
shooting the guy shooting the guy in the
back many times i mean
couldn't you have done something
different couldn't you have wrestled
you know i mean in the meantime he might
have been going for a weapon and
you know there's a whole big thing there
but they joke just like
in a golf tournament they miss a three
foot you're not comparing it to golf
because of course that's what the media
i'm saying people choke people people
outrageous analogy of course and laura
ingram realizing it and trying to do
instant damage control for donald trump
but it just kept getting worse and worse
this next clip is a really interesting
insight
into the psyche really of donald trump
take a look at this
feel like me they feel like every time i
put law and order up
on social media it gets such an
incredibly
positive response the people of this
country will not stand for it
so trump recognizes whenever he
posts a tweet law and order in
all caps a lot of people like it it gets
a good response
notice that he's saying i get a good
response not when i
do anything but when i post law
and order this is a microcosm of the
entire presidency during the chris
wallace interview in july
this is by the way i tweeted about this
this is relevant to bring up trump said
during the chris wallace interview in
july
within two weeks we will have a signed
and delivered new health care law
it's going to replace obamacare it's
going to be done in two weeks that was
in july
that came and went during august trump
was asked about it he said
we're going to do it at the end of the
month and trump is start saying trump's
doing new health care trump's doing
health care
as you probably know it's now september
august 31st came and went and trump
didn't do it
trump either recognizes or simply
doesn't care
that he doesn't actually need to do
stuff
he gets a lot of the political benefit
just from saying he's going to do it and
that's exactly what he's saying here
when he says
i post law and order and people
absolutely love it
then trump went into wild conspiracies
about the city of portland for example
which he claims has been burning for
years
they say that when you walk through the
streets of
portland this is years and years of
burning and
it's not the last 90 days it's been
really no no it's been
horrible in the last 90 days but no it's
been going on for many it's been going
on for
many many years it's like you're in
i i won't name the city but it's a city
someplace in the world that's not so
good okay
it's a terrible city the oregon governor
said portland has been
burning from years like what is that
what does that even mean
firefighters just let things burn for
years
import none of this makes sense the
facts don't matter
but this is the narrative trump has
chosen trump has staked out
this place in order to get himself from
now until election
the election he's made the calculation
it may work it may not
that chaos is good for him even though
the chaos is happening under his watch
it may work and it may not and i got
some interesting pushback yesterday from
people writing and saying david
here's why your take is wrong the chaos
won't work for donald trump
and we'll discuss that but the point is
trump thinks it will help him
he was asked would he put dr fauci in
charge
again if you were to do it all over
again you had to do it all again i know
that's
kind of a hard question but do it all
again would you put fauci
front and center every day in charge of
the coronavirus task force i get along
with him very well i disagree with a lot
of what he said he said keep it
open for china that was a big mistake
and he admits it
i just i get along with him but every
once in a while he'll come up with one
that i say
where did that come from i inherited him
he was here he was a part of this huge
piece of machine i didn't put anybody in
charge he was here
he was he's been here for 40 years 84
19 okay he's been here for many many
years uh
but and i you know you inherit a lot of
people it's part of the machinery
he inherited fouchy he says sort of like
a stepchild that came with your partner
came with a relationship i inherited him
so no real answer
there and then again restating this
wild claim that he's done more for black
people than anyone except maybe abraham
lincoln but maybe even more than abraham
lincoln
anything for them i've done more and i
said in this speech some people
said you shouldn't say it it's too
aggressive i said what's aggressive
i've done more than any president in the
united in the history of our country
except for maybe abe and i say maybe
maybe abraham lincoln the reason i say
maybe is i'll explain that to you later
okay
all right the funny that every time
trump says this
nobody says what about lbj maybe
jonathan swann from axio said what about
lbj although i don't i don't remember
and if he said it i don't know that
trump even heard it
i'm going from memory but aside from the
lincoln conversation nobody mentions lbj
in this discussion it i can't even
pretend that this is serious but trump
continues to say it
and then here is where it gets really
just dystopian
in explaining that someone is secretly
controlling joe biden right now
donald trump suggests that there was
some kind of
thwarted terror plot against the
republican convention
involving thugs on a plane but he won't
go into detail
he's not controlling anything who do you
think is pulling biden's strings
is it former obama people that you've
never heard of
people that are in the dark shadows
people that
what does that mean that sounds like
conspiracy theory dark shadows people
that you haven't heard of they're people
that are
on the streets they're people that are
controlling the streets
we had somebody get on a plane from a
certain city this weekend
and in the plane it was almost
completely loaded with
with thugs wearing these dark uniforms
black uniforms with gear and this and
that they're
they're on a plane where's the words
i'll tell you sometime but
it's under investigation right now but
they came from a
certain city and this person was coming
to the republican national convention
and there were like seven people on the
plane like this person
and then a lot of people were on the
plane to do big damage
so is that completely made up
probably not it's probably not
completely made up it's probably a
combination
of something that happened which trump
first
misunderstood and then exaggerated
that's as i
apologize for hitting my microphone
there it's probably something trump
misheard and is exaggerating now for
some unclear and unknown benefits so
this is the president talking about you
know a plane loaded with thugs and black
uniforms i wonder if their uniforms were
the only things
that were black about those so-called
thugs that's certainly
a question and then he says he says this
person but was it a person or was it a
group
even laura ingram unable to save donald
trump and remember
donald trump's psyche allows him no
consideration
other than i'm going to crush this
interview i'm so smart i'm so good at
being interviewed
that everybody's going to come away
super impressed unfortunately
i think some of his followers do come
away from an interview like this super
impressed the reality is
absolutely horrifying almost as
horrifying as donald trump's press
briefing which i want to talk about next
so yesterday donald trump did his first
press briefing since the republican
national convention the first press
press briefing since the shootings over
the weekend it was insanely insane i
don't know any other way to describe it
it was a veritable
historic house of horrors let's just get
right into the clips now as you know
one of trump's supporters shot and
killed two people
in kenosha wisconsin and then we also
had
a trump supporter shot in portland
and trump comes out and he says i want
to give you an update about left-wing
violence in the united states take a
look
vaccine very rapidly in record time
i also want to provide an update on
left-wing
political violence that we're seeing in
democrat-run cities
under my administration federal law
enforcement is working with state and
local authorities
all over the country to comb through
hours of video track down writers
looters and arsonists and bring them
to justice we've just so before we go
any further i know many of you know
this just give me 30 seconds to remind
you most
politically based violence in the united
states is right wing period
the anti-defamation league has studied
this for a long time their latest report
from 2018
says 50 of 50 people killed in 2018 were
killed by
right-wing political extremism 78
percent were right uh white supremacists
16 were anti-government extremists
four percent were in cell extremists
and one guy was an islamist extremist
remember
i i think islamic extremism rightly
should be considered right-wing
uh because it is really not i mean
listen if you take religion to that
level and believe religion should be law
and that people should die over it that
is not a left-wing belief i've ever seen
but that was one guy okay so maybe it
was 49 out of 50
according to the adl csis
has identified that the overwhelming
majority of violence from extremists in
the u.s comes from white supremacists
anti-government small government
extremists
including militias and so-called
sovereign citizens
groups the center for investigative
reporting looked at this
from 2008 to 2016 they found that out of
a hundred they found 115 right wing
terror incidents
63 islamist inspired terror incidents
and 19 left-wing incidents overwhelming
violence is from the right
uh and then lastly the national
consortium for the study of terrorism
maintains these profiles in
radicalization
and they have found that radicalized
individuals since 1948 are
40 percent far right 25
islamist 17 percent far left and 18
single issue folks who could be anywhere
on the
on the political spectrum or outside of
it so don't ever allow yourself to be
distracted
the vast majority of political violence
is right wing
donald trump also claims without
evidence that left-wing protesters
have killed a lot of people in america
we will never surrender to mob
rule because if the mob rules democracy
is indeed dead
the reason we're continuing to see
violence in left-wing cities today is
that
liberal politicians mayors prosecutors
and judges are
refusing to enforce the law and put the
riders in jail these are riders these
are dangerous people
these are killers they kill a lot of
people donald trump given the
opportunity to condemn the pro-trump
protesters that were shooting paintballs
at people driving vehicles into people
pepper spraying people over the weekend
donald trump says well those were
peaceful protesters and he answers
cnn reporter caitlin collins by saying
that her supporters
her supporters her supporters are the
ones being violent
virus but first you were just
criticizing joe biden saying he didn't
mention the far left or antifa
during his speech today you said you
wanted to talk about left-wing political
violence
yeah but i noticed you did not mention
that your supporters were also in
portland this weekend
firing paintball guns at people some
form of pepper spray
so do you want to also take this chance
to condemn what your supporters did well
i understand they had large numbers of
people
that were supporters but that was a
peaceful protest and
paint is not and paint is a defensive
mechanism paint is not bullets
your supporters your supporters and they
are your supporters indeed
shot a young gentleman
who and killed him not with paint
but with a bullet and i think it's
disgraceful
these people they protested peacefully
they went in very peacefully
and i'll tell you what they're
protesting they're protesting when they
turn on television
or read whatever they may be reading and
they see
a city like chicago where 78 people were
shot
and 13 died or a city like new york
where the crime rate has gone through
the roof
or a city like portland where the the
entire city is
ablaze all the time and the mayor says
we don't want any help from the federal
government
when these people turn that on and they
see that they say
this is not our country this is not our
country that was a peaceful protest
totally
caitlyn collins supporters what what
does that even mean
and donald trump received a follow-up
question
he ended up defending kyle rittenhouse
the 17 year old supporter of his
who has now been charged with homicide
after killing two people
in kenosha wisconsin take a look
go ahead
[Music]
it was a supporter of yours mr president
is accused of killing
are you going to him the actions of
vigilantes like kyle rittenhouse
we're looking at all of it that was an
interesting situation you saw the same
tape as i saw
and he was trying to get away from them
i guess it looks like
and he fell and then they very violently
attacked him
and it was something that we're looking
at right now and it's under
investigation but
i guess he was in very big trouble he
would have been
he probably would have been killed but
it's under it's under investigation
do you think private citizens should be
taking i'd like to see law enforcement
take care of everything
i think everything should be taken care
of law enforcement but again we have to
give our cops back our police back their
dignity
the respect they're very talented people
and of course donald trump
continuing to insist that joe biden
won't condemn violence now joe biden
gave a speech yesterday where he
condemned all violence he actually said
if it's from the right or from the left
i condem all violence
it was it couldn't have been more direct
and simple
and donald trump who does not condemn
all violence
simply repeats biden won't condemn it
concerns though that it could
exacerbate tensions and increase
violence do you give any
uh consideration well it could also
increase enthusiasm
and it could increase love and respect
for our country
and that's why i'm going because they
did a fantastic job as soon as i called
and told them let's go the whole problem
stopped that was what success
now of course um donald trump here
he could be right he might not be when
he says that
the tensions and the unrest could
increase voter enthusiasm we heard from
kellyanne conway yesterday
she said very clearly trump believes the
unrest will help him
maybe it will maybe it won't i think
there is a case to be made
that a more systemic analysis like that
done by
election predictor alan lichtman may be
more accurate from the standpoint of
saying
systemically how is the economy doing
these major kind of qualitative factors
are more important in influencing the
election
it's not inconceivable that on the
margins in the two months between now
and the election
maybe unrest will activate more of the
donald trump base
and get them to vote it won't
necessarily change people's minds but it
might activate
certain parts of the electorate i don't
know
lastly donald trump was asked not to go
to kenosha wisconsin a reporter said did
you
consider listening to the requests of
the governor and the mayor and trump
says nah
mr president are you giving any
consideration or
did you give any consideration to the
governor and mayor's request
not to come to kenosha tomorrow no
because kenosha was something we did a
good job when the governor didn't want
us there
he didn't want the national guard as you
know
he was very reluctant but i give him
credit because ultimately he said yes
and as soon as he said yes the problem
ended
but i have to see the people that did
such a good job for me and we're meeting
with
numerous people and we have tremendous
support in the state of wisconsin
so will this work that's what i want to
hear from you about
will trump trying to foment and then
capitalize on unrest
sort of playing arsonist and firefighter
is this a strategy that you believe on
balance in the net net net
will be helpful for trump going into the
election
or not uh i want to hear from you we'll
have continued coverage of this
on our instagram page at david pakman
show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
for the last um several weeks i i've
really made it a point
not to talk much about q anon
and uh what it is and at this point i
think i have to
because it is actually starting to
become um
something that is of interest to my
audience
and and unfortunately maybe even
relevant in some
broader sense so to talk to us about it
today we're going to be speaking with
alex kaplan
who's a senior researcher at media
matters focuses on social media
misinformation disinformation and online
extremism
uh great to have you on alex thanks for
having me on
so i mean okay i guess to start with it
clearly this q anon is substantial
enough
that an organization like media matters
is paying attention
you're tracking it you're researching it
it how do we establish
how much of a thing this is yeah
so um i would say until recently it was
hard to get a sense
of exact numbers for how many supporters
uh there were from kirilanon there were
definitely signs that it was significant
um in the last uh few weeks
we've gotten um some reporting that has
finally given a sense maybe more
concrete numbers there was a report
uh from nbc news that uh
according to a facebook review of
queuing on facebook groups it found
i believe at least three million members
of q and on facebook groups so i mean
there could be overlap between
groups some of the groups but i think
that gives a sense that
there is a significant amount of people
that
are sympathetic subscribe to cert
traffic in this conspiracy theory online
if someone does not know what the
conspiracy theory is
what are the kind of highlighted bullet
points of it
yeah so uh it's an extremist conspiracy
theory that started in late 2017
um on a message board site called
4chan which is known for hosting
anonymous white nationalist trolls
essentially
um its premise is that there is this
anonymous
entity called calling itself q claiming
to have q security clearance in the
government
claiming to have this inside scoop on
this secret plot that president trump
is involved in that actually originally
involved special counsel robert mueller
to take down the deep state his
perceived enemies
uh this pedophile network this global
cabal
of like pedophiles that includes
democrats um
and that they'll be basically walked
into thrown in the guantanamo and my
court-martialed
um that uh that's kind of the premise of
it and it moved to
another even more extremist site uh
message board site called a chan which
is
got shut down because it was tied to
white nationalist shooters
are alleged by national shooters and is
relaunched as a site called acon
so that's where it is now and that's
basically its premise some elements of
this remind me of a uh
blacklist episode i think james spader
was uh involved in the in the direction
of that particular episode but but in
all seriousness
so this is this is a pro-trump ideology
that that frames trump as a sort of
savior or
white knight for lack of a better term
in the in the global context
yes uh it is a pro-trump conspiracy
theory
that uh claims that he's going to uh
what they call like the storm this event
where like all the enemies are
all their perceived enemies are going to
be like mass arrested and
court-martialed
um and yeah i mean the conspiracy theory
supporters traffic in pro-trump
narratives pro-trump content
um the heart of the conspiracy theory as
you said is that uh
trump is the savior the central figure
of this secret plot
so this is not just online
and this is maybe why we're now taking
it more seriously which is that there
are
you'll tell me the number but certainly
more than 10 candidates
for congress at the national level who
are
at least to some degree affiliated with
q anon
yeah so um over the course of my
tracking
uh i have come across at least uh
78 current or former congressional
candidates
78 that have at some level
expressed some kind of support for the
conspiracy theory so that inclu it does
include former candidates but candidates
that all
ran at some point in 2020 for congress
so
because it's very easy to run in some
kind of
nominal sense in terms of right now
in terms of on the ballot in november
what would the number be
so at least uh 20 of those 78 have
secured a spot on the ballot in november
of those 2019 are republicans and one is
an independent
um it is possible that number will go up
because there are some primaries left to
go
and are these individuals well let's
work backwards i mean when donald trump
in a press briefing
i think it was last week but it might
have actually been two weeks ago at this
point
it was probably two weeks ago during the
dnc was asked about this
he kind of played dumb but also said it
sounds like they're saying i'm doing
good things and of course that's a
really good way to get trump to say
at least not negative things about you
to what degree has this administration
commented beyond that one event on cue
so yeah as you said trump made a comment
uh or
remarks making saying positive things
about the conspiracy theory and
supporters
um it you know leading up to this
trump himself has amplified queueing on
promoting accounts by my account more
than 200 times
um and there were other people in
trump's orbit that have winked at
amplified q and r content um his social
media advisor dan scavino has linked at
the conspiracy theory
a few months ago i found uh he posted or
posted an image
on facebook uh uh of a photo that had a
cue in it and i was able to trace it
back to a q anon supporter that had
posted on his facebook page
um his son one of his sons eric trump
posted a q a on graphic on instagram
which he then took down without any
explanation it was a clear q and on
graphic
uh his former social media national
security adviser michael flynn
uh in july posted a video of himself
taking an oath
uh supporting q anon an oath that cue
the entity behind q anon had posted
uh i believe it was a couple of weeks
before um and
and some of his uh campaign staff have
gone on a q a on
youtube channel so uh there were
connections
uh before this we're going to go to a
brief break on the podcast but we'll
continue our conversation with the media
matters alex kaplan you'll find the full
conversation on our youtube channel
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so i want to spend just a little bit of
time fact checking
one particular retweet that has been the
source of a lot of controversy from
donald trump's completely unhinged
tweet tweetstorm the other day and i
wanna
really think about this in the context
of the chaos pr
paradigm that we've been discussing the
idea that
maybe donald trump benefits from unrest
sort of
either way no matter which side the
unrest is coming from
or whether donald trump actually solves
it the idea that trump may benefit from
it either way donald trump
one of donald trump's retweets during
during his recent tweet storm
is arguably his most blatant act
of racial incitement that we've seen and
this was a tweet storm that was
triggered right after
a right winger was shot and killed in
portland although donald trump was
remaining very quiet
on kyle rittenhouse the kenosha
wisconsin shooter
and within the tweet storm donald trump
retweeted a video
that was originally posted by a user
named
i'm with griper which is a right wing
group they've
since changed their name on twitter to
try to seem as though they are
associated with
antifa in any case that doesn't really
matter
the video shows a scuffle on a subway
platform
in new york city completely out of
context which ends
when an unidentified black man
pushes a bystander who's a white woman
woman
into a subway car it's completely out of
context
and in fact it happened in 2019 it has
literally nothing to do with what's
going on right now and the unrest
that trump is trying to use to uh
defend or perpetuate his presidency
the retweet has since been deleted
but as you can see we still have it
originally from username
tdn noticias which is news
or headlines in spanish uh
author and former speechwriter for
george w bush david frum
commented on this calling it quote the
most blatant
act of racial incitement in the history
of that office
not even andrew johnson went this far
and it is indeed a completely out of
context
video this video of a scuffle in 2019
on a subway platform has nothing to do
with black lives matter
it has nothing to do with the protests
that are going on it has nothing to do
with george floyd
or kenosha or portland or anything and
in fact if you research the story
you will find out that this individual
was charged
for shoving this woman on the subway
and there is of course in the widespread
reporting about the incident
no mention whatsoever about an
affiliation with a social movement on
the right or on the left
but this is a perfect example of how any
random video
any random incident any random event
even a picture
is repurposed by white nationalists and
the president then ends up boosting it
now
did trump fall for it was trump
tricked here or did he knowingly retweet
something that he knew was from 2019
it actually doesn't matter because the
goal is just to be a dog whistle the
goal
is to amplify these messages that donald
trump believes are beneficial to him
it's very telling that regularly
his instinct is like put aside the facts
this has not this video this shoving
incident had nothing to do with blm
it wasn't even this year it wasn't even
in the cities trump is talking about
but trump recognized it as a message
or image that was beneficial to him and
it just so happens to be something that
was put out there by white nationalists
and it's because donald trump
has decided stoking racial tensions is
good for me
stoking unrest is good for me creating
racial division is good for me he may be
right
and he may be wrong the calculation
would be
it activates more of his people than
biden's people to see this type of stuff
amplified by the president
anybody who opposes black lives matter
in my experience will use anything any
black person has ever done to try to
make their point
even if it has nothing whatsoever to do
with black lives matter
and that's what we're seeing here now
i've gotten a few emails from people
recently saying you know david
you used to be critical of black lives
matter
and now you seem to have fallen in line
have you been
bullied by the left no
uh you are 100 correct that as an
organization i have been critical of
black lives matter in the past and i
maintain every single one of those
criticisms the anti-semitic edge
the disagreement on tactics the uh
belief that
much of what has been done some of what
has been done is counterproductive to
the cause
but i am not going to fall into the
criticisms
that are wildly racist from the right
about black lives matter and more
importantly
the primary message of black lives
matter is one that i agree with
it's a disagreement on tactics and and
on certain elements of it but
mike the difference is my criticisms of
blm
are based on things that have actually
happened not random videos from 2019
that have absolutely nothing to do
whatsoever with black lives matter or
anything that's being discussed right
now
okay another fact check that i want to
do
this is a really good opportunity to
talk about this new talking point
that is spreading that only nine
thousand americans died of coronavirus
now you might hear that and say oh nine
thousand
hundred and eighty something thousand is
the official death toll where on earth
are you getting
that i'm going to tell you exactly where
it comes from
and in fact donald trump tried
amplifying this talking point
and retweeted a tweet that twitter
removed
because it was spreading disinformation
about coronavirus 19. so the original
tweet was posted
by a user with the username littlemel
has been removed and it now says this
tweet is no longer available because it
violated the twitter
rules the story that that tweet which
donald trump retweeted
told is one that alleges that
new cdc data proves coronavirus
was only the cause of death in six
percent
of the deaths so far and that for all
other coronavirus deaths
the real cause of death was one two
or even three other conditions or causes
and what a lot of right wingers are
seizing on
is that six percent number and saying
look only 9 000 people
really died of coronavirus now that
tweet
was removed donald trump also retweeted
a post by one of
his attorneys jenna ellis with the link
to a story on a far-right conspiracy
website
also based on the same coronavirus 19
conspiracy
that retweet hasn't been removed and it
says
if you're looking very dramatically
shock report
the the cdc quietly updated covid
numbers
only 9200 died from coronavirus alone
the rest had different other serious
illnesses
now i'm going to explain the talking
point to you
but i actually wonder do you think trump
believes only 9 000 people really died
of coronavirus
or do you think he's retweeting this
stuff because he knows that there's a
political advantage to doing it
i actually am unsure but it boggles the
mind how anyone could look at the data
and say oh
no these people didn't really die of
coronavirus so
let me give you an analogy to what they
are saying this would be like saying
most gunshot victims don't die of a
gunshot
they die of bleeding out and so gunshots
aren't really that deadly but listen if
you're gonna bleed out that's a
completely different story
that's essentially the the argument that
they are making what they are trying to
say is
the 94 of coronavirus deaths that had an
additional comorbidity
weren't really coronavirus deaths and of
course this misses the point that
the way lots of people end up dying from
communicable disease
is because they have an underlying
compromised immune system
or they have another condition that
makes the virus or whatever disease
we're talking about more dangerous or
deadly
and the idea they're trying to spread is
if you're healthy you don't really have
anything to worry about
and therefore we don't need to be doing
all the social distancing we don't need
masks we don't need shutdowns we don't
need any of this stuff
now there's a couple different reactions
to this first of all
40 of americans are obese and obesity is
an aggravating factor for coronavirus so
if you want the make the to make the
case that if you have no comorbidity
you are really really safe um forty
percent of americans have a major
comorbidity with which is obesity so
even if this was accurate in some way in
some
fundamental sense it doesn't seem like
this gets a lot of people off the hook
that's number one
number two this is something
that if it were to become widely
believed
would be very dangerous because it would
simply encourage
dangerous behavior including from people
who do have comorbidities
a lot of people don't even understand
the concept of a co-morbidity
and risk factors and aggravating factors
so
this would be the type of stuff that
twitter should be policing in general
but not that what you would expect to
see posted by a president of the united
states
but it is indeed being posted by the
president of the united states and
twitter is regularly having
to actually deal with donald trump's
tweets another retweet from trump was
recently removed
for falsely claiming that there was a
cure for coronavirus
twitter moderators have also had to deal
with donald trump's tweets
um that were glorifying violence the
reality is donald trump if he were not
president
likely would have been banned from
twitter a long time ago and yet they
continue to insist that twitter's bias
is actually an anti-conservative
more than it is uh and anti-liberal very
very weird stuff
we have a voicemail number which is 2192
david p
uh the term cultural marxism is one that
is being bandied about by some on the
right recently
that's exactly what today's voicemail
deals with let's take a listen to it and
then i'll tell you about it
here we go hey david this is stephen
from virginia
and i uh just wanted to talk to you
about uh i've been seeing
a lot of people throw around the phrase
cultural marxism
and i i don't know if you know that or
other people know that but that's
kind of a call back to the conspiracy of
cultural bolshevism uh from world war ii
and and the nazis and it's a pretty
anti-semitic
sort of uh dog whistle it is so
anytime you hear someone talk about
cultural marxism
it should be a red flag for you that
absolutely
and cultural marxism the
cultural marxism is presented by the
right as some kind of serious thinkers
hypothesis it's really a conspiracy
theory with some significant
anti-semitic twists
it's kind of like political correctness
on steroids and the idea is that
the originators of cultural marxism who
are often jewish when you look at the
theories
are secretly trying to
subvert the culture of the united states
into a marxist culture so it's less
about economic marxism
but it's the idea of often jewish
philosophers
sometimes involving colombia university
figuring out a way to subvert american
society and culture
with cultural marxism rather than than
economic
marxism and it is it is bigoted
it's quacky and wacky and uh
so there's a lot of different flavors
where sometimes the perpetrators are
black people
sometimes it's lgbt folks sometimes it's
the left
often it's jews and um it should be a
when you hear cultural marxism it should
indeed be a red flag and i'm glad that
the caller is pointing it out
we have a great bonus show for you today
don't miss it
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 off of a subscription when
you go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've also included the link
right underneath this video